all right Joe Biden K Harris have no
interest apparently to fix the Border
crisis they themselves created but the
house of Republicans they are now
determined to take action a group of
more than 60 GOP members led by the
Speaker of the House Mike Johnson they
did visit the Border today to see things
for themselves by the way something
Biden and KLA Harris may want to do
house Judiciary Committee chairman Jim
Jordan was on that trip earlier today he
joins us now so we have all these
budgetary battles that are upcoming to
me there are two huge priorities that
the Republicans well three actually the
Republicans need to take on one is the
Border because I believe it is a clear
and present danger uh especially with
all the people coming from Iran Syria
Afghanistan Egypt Russia and China uh
the the next issue I think is of great
importance is getting the $34 trillion
doll under control spending uh and the
third thing would be your investigation
uh will those things happen this
election
year
yeah I think they will Sean and you're
right you not only see the problem here
eight out of 10 Americans know that the
Border situation is a crisis they also I
think understand the magnitude of it
that they think it's a crisis because it
is 300,000 last month highest month on
record Sean and the pace we're on under
Joe Biden his administration the pace
we're on we will hit 12 million migrants
coming into the country in four years
that is why we just got to stop there
should be the the plan should be no more
migrants come into the country unless
there's some extenuating circumstances
for an individual no new migrants should
be allowed in the country one sentence I
think will do it that sentence is do do
not spend American tax dollars to
process or release into the country any
new migrant that's what we got to try to
get on every single piece of legislation
that we can and force Joe Biden to do
the right thing so Joe Biden we know
since he's been president by eliminating
the policies of Donald Trump that were
working we now allowed 8.3 million
people now Crossing that border uh all
pretty much unvetted including some of
very hostile regimes towards this
country some of our biggest geopolitical
foes uh didn't Joe Biden take an oath to
uphold the laws of our land our
constitution every law is based on that
document uh if I were
to is a president now allowed to just
pick and choose what laws they'll
enforce is a president allowed to Aid in
a bet in the law break by offering free
Transportation our Governors are allowed
to offer free health care like is now
being offered in States like California
forcing taxpayers to pay for people that
enter the country illegally is that now
our
future no you're exactly right when Joe
Biden took the oath of office on January
20th 2021 he's supposed to then go
enforce the law instead what he did that
very day Sean is issued a number of
executive orders and he changed policy
he said no more building the wall no
more remain in Mexico while we eval
valate an asylum Seeker claim and he
also said once you come to the country
you will be released to wherever you
want to go all across our our nation
people are going and everyone understand
that is why I think the American people
know that this is deliberate this is
willful this is purposeful he did this
he he was determined to do this and the
country understands just how wrong it is
that's why I think you're seeing the the
the 80% polling numbers that so
something has to done and what I think
has to be done is if he's not going to
pass the Bill if he's not going to pass
our bill then he should do that one we
should do that one sentence and put it
on
legislation will will may orcus be
impeached I think we're always driven by
the facts and the evidence I think the
facts and the evidence are pretty darn
compelling for him I also think the
evidence is compelling for Joe Biden
that's why we've actually entered an
impeachment inquiry phase took a vote on
impeachment inquiry and are moving
forward with the witnesses the Final
witness is we need to depose before we
make a determination but I think the
facts and the evidence are already
compelling for both individuals Jim
Jordan thank you so much as always hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else